Let's look at the solution to our test and
set quiz. We have a test and set instruction that
checks the memory location at the address defined in the
instruction. If that location is 0, then we write a
1 there and set the register to 1. If
the location is not 0, then we just set the
register to 0 without writing to the memory location. And
we want to use this to implement a lock function.
The way we do that is, we set R1 to 0, and then, as long as R1 is equal to 0,
we test and set lockvar and get the result of that instruction in R1. So, what
happens is, our R1 starts out at 0, so
we will enter this first iteration of the loop.
If the test and set finds the lock busy,
it's going to read lockvar, see that it's not 0,
return 0. And R1 stays 0, and we keep
looping. If, however, the test and set finds the
lockvar to be free, that means its memory location
is 0, then we do this. We set lockvar
to 1, thus changing the state of the lock to locked, and we return 1 in R1, so
that this loop will exit. So, we will only
exit this lock function once we acquire the lock, and
we will wait here as long as the lock is not available.